Magnus Carlson no it's onesie about let
me connect you one zeros one zero
yeah that's true
I mean the time is showing that six two
seven one could be eight zero
the direction is towards the logical
Direction yeah and yeah
I'm not sure his brings a so-called job
of a line but but it's just worse yeah
for white already yeah
okay Bishop B6 bring the Rooks
and this is very tricky to play for
white without time
yeah and also Magnus is so good in this
all these things yeah yeah
Place Italian Fabi yeah he should play I
mean he had excellent position actually
in this gambits and so on yeah maybe
forgot
I I mean that's my theory but you
believe it's insane yeah no maybe he's
hiding his path for the wall Blitz
already
but he already showed it a couple of the
games
oh
no this I don't know that's already a
disaster I mean even I think better to
resign and like to zero down and go next
time he already gave up yeah yeah yeah I
mean that was smart and it's not Fabi
style yeah